before getting into black widow
i read that you were discovered at like
13
in moscow and moved to paris at 16 to
become a model
and since i will never experience being
a model as you can
clearly tell i'm curious what what is it
like
to move to paris at age 16 to model
i mean what what is that experience like
um at that age it's exciting it's
exciting it's thrilling it's like oh the
whole world is changing
i'm part of a fairy tale you feel like i
felt like a cinderella like
an incredible thing that happened to me
that was not at all
written uh written on my past like it
could
like if you looked where i come from you
couldn't have predicted that that could
even happen to someone like me you know
i'm just so far away from it
tiny tiny small town in the south of
ukraine i mean it's just you know
i never traveled you know i wasn't you
know i wasn't part of a
wealthy family we didn't have the means
so normally i should have like
been born there and stayed there and
died there you know so it's it is
incredible
it's incredible that so much i was
excited
of course when i went you know in paris
i'm in paris everyone
everyone wants to go to paris you know
even if i had failed and
had to come back i would have at least
seen paris i would have said well i've
been there on a trip because
my family could have never paid me a
trip you know
to go to paris that's for sure what do
you think might surprise people to learn
about the modeling industry that maybe
they don't know
[Music]
lots of things i guess people well
people probably see it as glamorous and
you know and fun um and
uh well i didn't i i didn't see it like
this and i never saw it like this um
and uh what they would be surprised
about is to learn there could be a very
lonely experience
i have never felt so lonely in my life
as when i
was a model he was constantly that was
always by myself everywhere
going traveling by yourself packing by
yourself on the plane by yourself
arriving at a strange country by
yourself not knowing anyone
uh going there for three two three days
leaving going to another country
and monster and that's how you go by
yourself no friends
no connections nothing and i hated it
i hated being lonely i didn't hate the
jo like the job itself it was you know
it was fun and i was like it was fun
once i was
again in the character or like in makeup
and like working
in front of the camera uh that's all
that's a fun bit
but the outside of it traveling and
moving and being by yourself and never
being able to have a routine you know
have friends
get together with people you can because
you travel
you don't have stapes stability it's so
destabilizing
so i don't think people think about it i
didn't deal well with it
at all but let's not get in there along
with the long story
i'll leave it there and just say that's
so interesting because i would never
think of it like that and i'm glad you
shared that jumping into why i actually
get to talk to you
talk a little bit about meeting with
marvel for this role did you
did they how did you get involved in
this project
well it was uh it's an offer that came
through
and um i thought about it for about 10
years and then i'm kidding
and i said yes immediately i thought it
was really great
i thought it was cool and yeah jumped on
on board did they tell you um
everything about the character when you
got the offer or was it more like we're
looking at you for this marvel project
yeah just sign me up
well you know no there's like the whole
obviously the description that comes
through the visuals the script
i read i read the story you know
obviously then there were discussions
with uh
with the director kate and and then
later with like
with my co-stars as well you know it's
all it's it's a it's a process
it's a it's a teamwork and little
different bits you discuss with
different people you know costumes
makeup
you you discuss with those departments
and
uh it's slowly you build it up you know
and like on my side i was just
obviously yeah trying to concentrate it
on the humane part of the character
that's behind that suit and
you know and to make sure that
it's not one-sided it's not just this
killing machine
which seems to be cold-blooded that
there is actually
a soul underneath and there is a a
character
a person that's suffering and that's
gone through a lot
and uh and there is so much that can be
explored
behind that um i love learning about the
behind the scenes of the making of a
movie um is there anything that you
think might surprise people to learn
on your side about the making of black
widow well
yeah well the the obviously my costume
is uh quite complicated and the
uh i was in makeup for hours in the
beginning uh
well in the beginning in the beginning
of each day um
it took hours because obviously without
giving spoilers there's a lot to to that
had to be done with
my face and my head and everything and
then
the costume that consists of many layers
that like
had to had to involve more than like two
people i think
like three people helping me um
um it's uh what else well i i had to be
a secret so i was walking through uh
either studios or
location wherever we were filming i had
to walk underneath an umbrella
that had fabric attached to it on all
sides
all the way down to the floor so and i
was
hidden underneath and i would look where
i'm going through like a
through like a cut in fabric and that's
how i
moved from point a to point b um and
that yeah i guess people
probably well normally you don't do that
like i've done other films i never had
to walk under an umbrella
hidden but i think it was such a
you know we had to keep it secret so it
was a
very interesting existence
when when on set and that i was going to
say that's something that marvel is
famous for is the secrecy but it also
pays off
because then you you know it's a
surprise to audiences
yeah i know i think i think it's i think
it was worth it totally i'm glad we and
i
i can't believe we pulled it off uh we
all kept it
you know um came to the secret and it
worked i mean how
but also like one year is long time but
two years it's incredible
and uh and it it worked out it's still a
surprise and people seem to have no idea
uh who was behind the the mask and uh
so it's great that the secret is the
revelation and surprise is working
you never know with marvel as to whether
or not your character can come back
be in another movie have you had any
conversations with them
about uh your character being in
something in the future
uh and you know i you i think that's a
question to marvel
uh that's another you know you know one
of those things that i just
like i completely get it um i'm gonna
ask you about something completely
different i'm a fan of terence malik
and you got to work with him a number of
years ago what do you remember about
that experience working with him
oh he's a lovely human being lovely man
he was great working with him completely
different from everything like his way
of
filming his style is different and
whenever something is different
to me personally i embrace
differences and challenges instead of
like being afraid of them or shocked by
them because i like
i like challenging myself and
uh so because it was completely
like i've never seen before uh it to me
it was uh i was
i was completely taken by it because
i like you know i like new i like not
knowing and you know
sometimes there were days where i had no
idea
how it was going to end you know
normally the days planned on on set
we know it's very like scheduled with
him it's like so
it's chaotic and it's flowing and
and things are spontaneous and it's
another way of doing a movie it's a
completely different
way but it's also possible and i loved
his style i loved his way
i love the silences and yeah
it's i'll never forget that moment oh
you make me you make me think of him i
should text him we're still in patch we
text
each other and he's like how how are you
he's like we're really we
kept in touch he's such a great guy you
know we're always like
ask each other about how it's going so
yeah i need to text him
yeah uh the thing that's interesting
about him in his films is that so many
actors i've spoken to that have worked
with him
uh they'll work for a while on a project
and then they could be in the movie for
30 seconds
or they could be in the movie for an
hour there's no way of knowing until
they see it that is true and i did i did
i did make a joke
i asked him i said look terence i know
the deal
i said look you've filmed me for hours
i know but i can i also know that i can
i said
did you cut me out i said are you
cutting me out
he's like no no you're gonna be there
you're gonna be like yeah
i said okay let's see let's see the
result and then like
wow okay actually it actually didn't cut
me out so yeah that was
it was a pleasant surprise um but yeah i
was expecting it
believe me i i knew i knew but you know
what
he even if he had cut me out
i swear to you it's i would have still
i'm i would have never regretted it i
just loved
i mean the result is something else it's
like another thing
but there's also the experience there's
the result in the experience of movie
and
sometimes they can coincide they can
both be great
or they can both be bad or one can be
great another not so great or the
vice versa and with him the experience
uh was amazing and worth it even if the
movie never came out
just that i lived through those days
with him
uh surrounded with his crew doing those
things
under getting into the psychology it was
worth it and it was uh
it was only my growth in my life and it
was good for me as a person
and i value that and that's all that
matters to me
on that note i need to stop i'm just
going to say congratulations
on black widow and thank you so much for
uh giving me your time
thank you